Now, many of the people watching this talk
by now will have had one, two,
three or even four doses
of a messenger RNA vaccine.
With billions of these shots now in arms.
it’s clear that this new way
of making vaccines
is both remarkably safe
and incredibly effective.
But did you know it's not the vaccine
itself that's keeping you safe?
It's actually you.
Because the human body has amazing powers
to both prevent and cure disease
by making its own medicines.
You just need to know
what medicine to make.
And that's what your vaccine gave you.
Simply a set of instructions
for how to protect yourself
against SARS-CoV-2.
Now vaccines are only the beginning.
As I said before,
the advent of mRNA vaccines
is heralding in an entirely new
era of medicines.
mRNAs give us the ability
to not only prevent disease
but also treat previously
intractable disorders.
But before I get to that,
let's talk about what is this new
way of medicines really about?
Well, it all comes down to proteins.
Now, you may think of protein
as simply something that you need to eat,
an important part of your diet,
something that's important
for you to build muscle.
But it's not just muscle
that contains protein.
Protein makes up a huge fraction
of the incredibly complicated ecosystem
that's your entire body.
In many ways, your body functions
like a large city,
full of myriad buildings,
interconnected buildings,
with lots of different structures.
Now, just as the word "building"
fails to capture the incredible variety
of structures that make up any large city,
the generic term "protein" gives no clue
as to the incredible variety
of molecular architectures
at the molecular level.
Like buildings,
proteins are not monolithic.
Our body makes many proteins.
Some, like the collagen in our skin
that makes our skin tough but pliable.
Like the actin and myosin in our muscles
that enable us to move.
Or our blood is full of hemoglobin,
ferrying oxygen around.
Antibodies protecting us from disease,
and clotting factors
that close up our wounds.
And for any of you that have ever
cracked a biochemistry textbook,
this should look familiar.
This is the metabolic chart
of the human body.
These are all of the reactions
in your body that are keeping you
alive and well right now.
And each one of those reactions
is catalyzed by a different protein
whose names are shown here in blue.
So proteins are not only
what makes up the bulk of your body,
they’re also what make your body tick
and keep you well.
Now, if we think again about buildings,
the structures of buildings
may look quite different in the end,
but they're all made
of a limited set of building materials
and which of those
building materials are used
and how they're arranged,
and how they're attached to one another
gives the buildings their final form.
The same is true of proteins.
If we zoom down to the molecular level,
we can see that proteins,
if we unravel their
three-dimensional architecture,
are actually just long strings
of building blocks.
And these building blocks
have different shapes
and different propensities
to interact with one another.
So it's which building blocks are used
and the order in which
they are in the chain
that gives a protein
is three-dimensional shape.
Now here I'm only showing three proteins,
but creating and maintaining
a healthy human
requires the combined action
of over 100,000
different types of protein.
And our bodies make them all.
Thus our bodies
are remarkable protein factories.
At the molecular level,
the numbers are truly mind-blowing.
Each of the 30 trillion cells
in your body --
that's three with 13 zeros --
contains between one
and 10 billion protein molecules.
That means that you have
as many protein molecules in your body
as there are stars in the known universe.
Now each different cell type in your body
makes a different kind of protein,
a different set of proteins,
like the rods and cones in my eye
that are detecting light right now
and the neurons in my brain
that are interpreting that light
and enabling me to see you right now.
So they make a particular set
of proteins unique to it.
And like any complex building project,
you can imagine that the process
of protein synthesis
needs to be tightly regulated
so that the right protein is made
at the right time and in the right place.
But of course,
with anything so complicated,
it's perhaps not surprising
that there's an occasional mistake,
a fault in the algorithm.
Let's go back to that metabolic chart.
It’s estimated that
one in 1,000 newborns
are born without the ability to make
one of the proteins on this chart.
Therefore, they have
lifelong complications
due to inborn metabolic errors.
Let's take just one of those.
Let's talk about von Gierke's disease
or glycogen storage disease I.
This is due to the lack of a protein
circled here in red,
whose job it is to release stored sugars
so that you can maintain
a healthy blood sugar level
while you're fasting.
So von Gierke's disease
patients can't fast.
They must constantly eat
small amounts of carbohydrates,
including getting up
every one or two hours during the night
to eat raw cornstarch.
Now, imagine the toll
that this takes on parents.
If they are ever to miss
a feeding of their child,
their child could slip
into severe hypoglycemia,
seizures and possibly death.
But even if these patients
can keep up this endless feeding cycle,
they are plagued
by lifelong complications,
including delayed puberty,
frequent infections,
kidney disease and liver cancer.
So von Gierke's disease
is just one example of a disorder
where we know what protein is missing.
What if we could give those patients back
the ability to make that missing protein?
Then we could actually treat their disease
instead of just managing their symptoms.
And that's where mRNA comes in.
That's also where I come in.
You see, I spent the better part
of my career as an academic
doing curiosity-based research
into the fundamental principles
of how proteins are made.
And my specialty was messenger RNA.
Like proteins, messenger RNAs
are long chainlike molecules
composed of building blocks.
The four building blocks
that make up messenger RNAs
form what is known as the genetic code.
As their name implies,
messenger RNAs carry messages:
messages that are translated by your body
in order to create proteins.
Thus messenger RNAs
are the language of life.
And the human body has a lot to say.
So, like proteins,
your cells are chock-full
of messenger RNA.
Every one of your 30 trillion cells
has hundreds of thousands
of messenger RNA molecules.
Messenger RNAs are an essential component
of all living organisms.
So when you are eating protein-rich foods,
you're not only eating protein,
you're also eating lots of messenger RNA.
Your body takes the messenger RNA
in the food that you consumed,
breaks it down into those component parts
and then builds new messenger RNAs
specific to your needs.
Now this continual
destruction and rebuilding
is a feature true of almost all proteins
and messenger RNAs in your body.
Let's take, for example,
the circadian clock.
This is the timer in your body
that tells you when to be active
and when to sleep.
The proteins that make up this clock
appear and disappear
with remarkable regularity every day.
The way that this is accomplished
is that your body makes the messenger RNAs
that encode those proteins
appear and disappear every day.
Every day for your entire life,
you get your daily dose
of clock messenger RNAs
producing clock proteins.
Now three properties of proper medicines
are that their effects
are of limited duration,
that their effects are dose-dependent
and that they can be given
over and over again
to produce the same effect.
mRNA's are transient.
The amount of protein produced
is dependent on how much
of that mRNA is present.
And they can be induced
over and over again
to produce the same effect.
So wow, it seems so simple.
If we could treat a disease,
if there's a protein
that's missing to treat a disease,
then we could simply give a few copies
of an mRNA to the body
for it to produce that protein.
If that protein's only needed once,
then maybe a single dose would suffice.
If a protein is needed multiple times,
then we can dose mRNA over and over again.
And that's exactly what's happening.
So when I went on
clinicaltrials.gov this morning,
it turns out that there are
over 175 clinical trials now open
using mRNA-based medicines
that are recruiting patients.
Another 54 clinical trials
are waiting in the [wings],
ready to be opened.
So there is a coming tsunami
of mRNA medicines.
Last year, Moderna and AstraZeneca
reported positive results
from a clinical trial where patients
during open heart surgery
were dosed with messenger RNA injected
directly into their heart muscles,
that told their heart muscles
to grow new blood vessels
in order to get around clogged arteries.
In other clinical trials
we're repeatedly dosing patients
with inborn metabolic errors
to treat their metabolic disease.
In fact, one of those clinical trials
that's currently recruiting patients
is for von Gierke's disease.
And for cancer patients, we're creating
personalized cancer vaccines.
These vaccines
are meant to train their bodies,
their immune systems,
to attack their cancers.
These are truly personalized medicines,
one vaccine for one person.
Now for personalized cancer vaccines
to be the most effective,
we need to get them made and back
to the patient as quickly as possible.
We aim for a turnaround time of 45 days.
By January of 2020,
we had already manufactured,
quality-controlled and delivered
to several dozen patients
personalized cancer vaccines.
So we had the know-how and the capacity
to manufacture vaccines quickly.
Thus, when the sequence
of the SARS-CoV-2 virus
was posted to a public web server
on January 10, 2020,
we got immediately to work.
Within two days, we had agreed
with our collaborators at NIH
on exactly which form of the spike protein
to put in our vaccine.
Because we had done so
so many times before,
it then took our mRNA design team
just one hour to design the mRNA
that we immediately --
(Applause)
That we immediately put on
to our manufacturing equipment.
We were then able to make that RNA,
get it quality-controlled,
fill-finished and shipped off to NIH
for the clinical trial in 45 days.
Now what I find --
(Applause)
What I find truly remarkable
is that that mRNA sequence
that took us one hour to design
is the same mRNA sequence
that went into your arms,
that ended up in Spikevax,
our now fully approved vaccine.
One hour to design a medicine
that has saved countless lives.
(Applause)
It still gives me goosebumps
every time I talk about it.
So what does the future hold?
Well, I've already told you
about regenerative medicine
and personalized cancer vaccines.
For cancer patients, we can send in --
by directly injecting
messenger RNA into their tumors --
we can send in instructions
telling the tumor cells to self-destruct,
Or having the tumor cells
send out signals to the immune system,
beckoning the immune system to attack.
For patients with autoimmune disorders,
we can send in signals that tamp down
their overactive immune systems.
And we and others are rapidly making
many more messenger RNA vaccines.
Because messenger RNA vaccines
can be produced so quickly and rapidly,
they're really well suited
for newly emerging diseases
as well as other viruses, like the flu,
where new variants come out every year,
and the vaccines need to be updated.
But one of the exciting things
about mRNA medicines
is we're not limited
to sending in the instructions
for one protein at a time.
mRNA medicines can be easily multiplexed.
Therefore, we're working
on a combination vaccine
for COVID, flu
and respiratory syncytial virus, or RSV:
all leading causes of hospitalization
and death in the elderly.
And we're hoping that this
will then be an annual booster,
that you will get,
just like the flu vaccine.
(Applause)
So finally, the very modest footprint
of the manufacturing equipment
for making messenger RNAs
means that they can be made
almost anywhere in the world.
And to take this to an extreme,
the American Defense Department
started a program in 2019,
and we're working with them
to miniaturize the entire process
so that it can be fit
into a single shipping container
for rapid deployment
anywhere in the world.
So --
(Applause)
So to finish, I hope I've convinced you
that we have entered
an entirely new era of medicine.
Having learned to speak the language
of mRNA, the language of life,
we can now use it to create medicines
that are just for one person,
like a personalized cancer vaccine,
or can be rapidly produced
and distributed to entire populations,
like the COVID-19 vaccines.
And the best part?
The best part is we're simply tapping
into your body's own ability
to make its own medicines.
Thank you.
(Applause)